many European countries have closed
their borders to try to curb the spread
of the corona virus and the effects are
having an impact on some communities
more than others
lockdown measures in France have hit
migrants particularly hard many are in
the northern port city of Calais from
where they hope to cross the sea to
England conditions and migrants shelters
were bad before but many say the
lockdown has made them even worse DWS
Lisa Lewis visited migrant shelters of
northern France and spoke to people
there about how the country's response
to the coronavirus crisis is affecting
them there's no let-up in police
procedure even in these times of kovat
19 we are asked to move on because we
want to film what's been an almost daily
routine since 2018 migrants are told to
move their tents a few metres once the
police have left the migrants put the
tents back no one here wanted us to film
their face but the migrants told us they
feel harassed they don't see us as human
beings they don't respect us they kick
my foot if you don't wake up when they
come they take away your tent then we
have to ask aid workers for a new one
and wait for up to a week trying to
observe social distancing here is
difficult sanitary conditions are bad
we're not allowed to go into town since
the beginning of the pandemic we've been
stuck in these camps some of us were
taken to shelters but we had to stay up
to four people in a room that's illegal
the migrants try to support each other
as best they can but that's also more
difficult these days this is where the
Calais jungle was until 2016 when it was
demolished at its peak
some 8,000 migrants lived in this camp
conditions were bad but migrants managed
to set up an infrastructure of sorts and
they were able to help each other out
now the authorities are trying to
prevent the migrants from constructing
another jungle by building fences like
this one
eight workers have had to reduce their
staff at the camp by half
they say the government's response isn't
helping the situation this is a real
step backwards for migrants human rights
there's no legal aid for them anymore
the evacuations continue and migrants
keep getting harassed by the police
you'd have thought people would stand
together in this crisis but these
vulnerable people are being left behind
but authorities say that medical teams
regularly check up on the migrants in
the camps and that the evacuations are
necessary we're offering shelter for up
to 715 migrants they can get medical
care 353 people have already taken up
that option the migrants are being
evacuated every two days if they are
camping illegally we need to prevent
them from settling aid workers say they
aren't enough shelters and many of the
migrants would rather stay here and try
to cross I'll never give up one day I
will get to England my dream is to
become a doctor have real freedom a nice
house and a nice life Mangus wants to
join two of his brothers who have
already settled in England but the
corona pandemic has now made reaching
the other side of the channel more
difficult than ever
DW is Leah Lisa Lewis who filed that
report joins us now from Paris Lisa your
report shows the difficult situation
migrants and refugees are facing in
northern France are the camps that
prepared for potential coronavirus
outbreak well that's a very good
question there were three confirmed
kovat 19 cases a few weeks back and
eight workers have told me that several
migrants there have been showing
symptoms that could mean they have kovat
19 but no testing is available really
and it's very difficult to keep a
distance in the camps even if the
migrants are camping outside but they're
crowded together especially when they're
cooking for example so if there were a
real outspread widespread a pandemic or
you know a real
lots of cases in the cams it would be
very difficult to contain them and to
take care of all the they either ill
people there it seems the people in the
camps are coming under increased
pressure from authorities who clearly
don't want them there but even if they
were to leave what they have anywhere to
go it's very difficult for many people
there and they've been many of them of
those I've been talking to have been on
the road for years five years eight
years ten years many of them have been
to other countries in the European Union
have been rejected when they fight for
asylum there and those I've talked to in
Kalev all said you know we are going to
try to cross across the English Channel
because in England they feel that they
can pass unnoticed and maybe find work
you know even if they don't have legal
papers but certainly it's a very good
question also because it's very
difficult for all these people to find a
place where can they can settle down and
have a nice life they so good to see you
that was DW is Lisa Lewis there in Paris
let's get a roundup of some of the
latest pandemic news around the world
right now German state premiers are
expected to approve a plan to allow all
shops to reopen and get Bundesliga
soccer going again with New Zealand
reporting no new cases for a second
straight day Prime Minister Justin down
dialed in to an Australian cabinet
meeting to discuss reopening borders
between the neighboring countries
Malaysia and India have begun to ease
part of their lockdown measures but both
governments have urged caution as cases
continue to rise and Thailand reported
its lowest number of new infections
since March 9th with no new case and no
new deaths let's get some analysis now
from Christian Lind Maya he's a
spokesperson for the World Health
Organization in Geneva mr. linnemeier
we're hearing a lot about lockdown
measures being relaxed infection rates
dropping etc is the worst of the
pandemic behind us I don't think we can
say that it's very normal and very good
in some ways that lockdown measures are
being eased people
I will not be able to hold this for much
longer that's how it looks and we need
to bring back some normal normality to
life and get the economy of course we
started or not damaged too much but the
problem with the corona Bryce with co19
is that it's not like a water faucet
it's being turned off and there's no
more dripping anymore to the contrary
it's actually dripping quite a bit still
the the infection rates the daily
infection rates have been lowered but
that means we still have daily infection
rates and we still have quite an amount
of cases we still have people in
emergency rooms we still have severe
cases and we still have unfortunately
deaths from coronavirus but what will be
happening now is that we need to learn
to live with the corona virus at least
for the foreseeable future in case we
have a vaccine so we need to learn to
deal on a daily basis with it where do
you see then the biggest risks the main
problem areas in fighting this pandemic
right now well first it's the infections
in itself and and it comes down to the
testing because the more we test every
suspect case the more we know and see a
complete picture we hear now reports
from different countries in the world
that there might have been cases even
earlier on when we didn't even know
there was corona circling that could be
possible but we need to look into this
but again the testing of every suspect
case would be highly important to
understand the picture we face in every
country around the world and when we
know this and we know how to respond and
we know how to hold events what to do in
schools how to bring children back how
to hold on to open businesses again and
this has an impact on everyday lives
looking at Europe what do you make of
the way that Germany is dealing with the
crisis particularly its eagerness to
reopen schools and the economy again so
bringing children back to to school is
really important because it's spring
normality back to their lives but it has
to be done in a step-by-step approach
the holo reopening has to done in a
step-by-step approach you ease a little
bit you monitor
your cases are climbing again or not and
that is possible because let's not
forget the whole idea of the lockdown
was to flatten the curve remember that
term it was to spread out the cases over
in the amount of time we never said it
would stop like cutoff it would spread
the cases out of an amount of time and
that's exactly what's happening right
now so with the step by step approach of
opening open a little bit more because
you see if it's working see if not too
many cases are arising so that the
health system can cope with it that the
hospitals can cope with it and then open
more and open more and open more where
this leads in terms of for example
vacations or what the normality will be
in August and September and October is
difficult to say right now
Germany seems to be doing well if you
look at the relation between infection
cases and and death rate that's because
that's nearly a leading situation in
Europe that that is good to see although
of course every death individually is
deplorable
mr. linnemeier thank you very much for
speaking with this that was Christian
lint Maya from the World Health
Organization in Geneva thanks Evan
research from a virus hotspot here in
Germany is shedding new light on the
spread of the virus in the country a
study from the hard-hit district of
Heinz Bayer estimates that only one in
ten coronavirus cases has been diagnosed
it's highlighting the dangers presented
by unidentified carriers as Germany
takes further steps to open back up its
economy the priority for these Germans
was pretty obvious killing at the
hairdresser's first thing on Monday one
basis for the discussion on further
easing of the rules might be found in a
newly published study on covert 19 cases
in the Western German District of
Hinesburg it suggests that 1.8 million
people may have been infected nationwide
ten times the number previously
confirmed a new and precise test for
antibodies could help verify the exact
number of infections so fairness the new
tests that Ross is presenting amounts to
an important milestone in the fight
against
virus getting these vehicles meanwhile
some states are pressing ahead
saxony-anhalt will now allow people to
meet up in groups of five lower saxony
announced the reopening of restaurants
Chancellor Merkel and others and her
coalition fear that if different regions
race to reopen it could undo the
successes achieved so far since open up
we're so close to the number where we
would have exponential growth again I
don't understand why we can't be a bit
more patient to secure what we have
achieved on Wednesday Chancellor Merkel
and the German state premiers will talk
about lifting more restrictions
yeah patience is a difficult thing these
days let's go to DWS chief political
correspondent Belinda crane she has more
tonight here in Berlin good evening to
you Melinda let's talk about this study
here but we're were there any big
surprises and if so what are their
implications moving forward for the
entire country
there was nothing totally unexpected but
a couple of things do stand out first of
all a significant share of those who
have been infected about a fifth overall
had no symptoms and this absolutely
underlines the importance of how we
behave as we begin to relax restrictions
on going back into public namely you
need to be wearing a mask you need to be
maintaining distance to other people
even if you feel fine because otherwise
you could infect them secondly that 1.8
million number more than 10 times as
many people appear to have been infected
as what was previously confirmed now
that goes to the question of herd
immunity the idea that we eventually
could get to a point where this virus is
less of a risk to health services and
less of a risk to society as a whole
because a lot of people have already
gotten it and become immune but the fact
is 1.8 million may sound like a lot but
that means they're still over 80 million
Germans who haven't had kovetz so we are
a long way from her
yeah a long way from herd immunity and
that brings me to what to the German
Health Minister you spawned what he was
talking about maybe a week or so ago he
about these so-called immunity passports
he has now reversed his decision to
introduce a document like this for the
time being why because there was a lot
of pushback after he made that proposal
and here's the thing people are very
worried that it would set up essentially
a two-class system where you've got one
group of people who've had kovat and
recovered and get an immunity passport
and can go back into society and work
and play as usual and then you've got a
second group who still need to be
protected people who haven't had the
virus now they in that second group
would have a very strong incentive to
try to get themselves into the other
category in other words maybe they would
stop taking precautions hoping to get a
mild case the buff of the virus and then
return to normal life and that clearly
is a situation with a lot of risks we
saw today in the country Malinda some
students were able to go back to school
today the federal states in Germany they
are the relaxing these restrictions of
public life and they're doing so in very
different ways why is that that's
correct
well the federal states do all have
rather disparate population and economic
situations and some of those moving
ahead like the state of North
rhine-westphalia are very populous
states and not terribly rich ones in
other words they're under a lot of
pressure to get people back to work to
try to get normal life started up again
but the fact is that there are real
risks for all states if some push ahead
faster than others because obviously
this virus doesn't respect either local
or national boundaries
meaning if one state pushes ahead so
fast that it sees a real upsurge in
infections that will undoubtedly spill
over to other states as well now the
Chancellor will be meeting with the
heads of the federal states on Wednesday
and you can be sure this is going to be
a big
for them our chief political
correspondent Melinda crane on the story
forest tonight here in Berlin Melinda as
always thank you what to do about the
crew the German Travel Group tewi is
planning to test nearly 3,000 cruise
ship workers quarantined aboard a liner
in the port of cooks Hoffmann - he says
that it's using one of its own cruise
liners called the my ship 3 to ferry
thousands of its employees home amid the
pandemic but the ship ran into trouble
when it docked in cook's oven in late
april with over a dozen crew members
exhibiting flu-like symptoms the cruise
ship that's now a quarantine station
the my ship 3 is part of the tui fleet
300 meters long with a 2500 passenger
capacity but no tourists are aboard only
crew and they're stuck with 8 confirmed
cases of coronavirus no one's allowed to
enter or leave authorities in cooks
Haven are testing almost 3000 people we
will put those people in seclusion and
in a special quarantine area on board as
well as the people they've been in
personal contact with we'll go on board
with what we call containment Scouts to
do contact tracing one deck of the ship
has been prepared for this in case
anyone else has to isolate event I
mentioned North Suzette's Lee he would
be at van Westin the cruise ship docked
in cook's havin a few days ago even if
some of the crew look relaxed the
situation has put their nerves to the
test the mostly non-german staff have
served for months at a time on various
ships of the 2e fleet after setting sail
from the Canary Islands they should have
been able to set foot on land but
physical and mental health issues have
surfaced on the quarantine ship the
cruise firm's management has declined to
grant any interviews
broken furniture after outbursts of rage
pregnant crewmembers and unpaid wages
these reports of some crew members show
very tense situation on board of the
many nationalities on the ship there
alone roughly eight hundred Filipinos
yet it's completely unclear how and when
they can be brought home some are indeed
eager to get home others dream of more
travel Martina and Hobart Wester camp
were aboard this very cruise ship in the
Caribbean when do you think you'll be
able to travel again I hope it'll be in
the next two or three months maybe not
abroad but in Germany I would think in
the meantime beach chairs sit empty on
the North Sea Shores the locals of kooks
often hope tourists will soon find their
way back and give the area a much-needed
boost Nigeria is beginning to lift the
lockdown in its two biggest cities Abuja
and Lagos it's part of an effort to get
Africa's largest economy back on track
after a month-long shutdown but many
fear that the country is rushing
prematurely to rollback restrictions and
in the process putting lives at risk the
bustle is back in Lagos though the virus
hasn't been vanquished crowds throng the
streets of Africa's most populous city
frequently ignoring physical distancing
rules and the requirement to wear a face
mask in public
many are relieved they can earn an
income again others worry new infections
will explode I'm very very happy now I'm
Bhima I'm in the market I've gotten some
money to feed my family people are
starving
complaining that I definitely to it and
the government did not issue anything as
an assistance for those odds in it is
not a good idea to live the lockdown
personally I felt he people are still at
home the
since they say virus disease will not
spread this great is who gets a cap and
now though they are easy lock down
that's what I think the easing of
restrictions comes with a significant
risk of overwhelming Nigeria's health
care system but in a country where 40%
of the population already live in
poverty and with the economic damage
mounting it's also necessary for the
day-to-day survival of those with no
other means of keeping themselves fed
and earlier we spoke to our
correspondent in Nigeria about the
pandemic and the damage that it has
brought to Africa's biggest economy well
the economy has taken the biggest hit
when it comes to the lockdown Lagos is
the epicenter of the corona outbreak in
Nigeria and Lagos is also the commercial
capital of Nigeria so which shops closed
businesses locked down everything
basically on hold you know what that
means for the country that basically
means that the economy has been put on
hold
not to add to the fact that Nigeria is
an oil dependent economy and so with the
collapse of the oil prices Nigeria's
economy has basically taken a huge hit
in the whole corner virus pandemic and
so experts are warning that the
Nigerians should prepare for the worst
when it comes to the economy